[Music]
yo what's good we are just about a week
away from the NFL Draft I got an awesome
interview with Josh Allen coming up at
about 10-15 minutes I brought in the man
the myth the legend Connor Rodgers from
stick to football because you've been
working all year for the draft that's
right so I need sort of like a week away
what everyone's talking about but Josh
Allen is great we talked about how he
thinks he could be a wide receiver in
the NFL he just doesn't want to take
someone's job because he's gonna impress
coaches so much I think he might have
played wide receiver at some point
you're gonna hear he was an all-state
wide receiver in Alabama yes what before
he moved back to New Jersey yes so the
interview is really great we were on a
shoot and I said can I get 45 minutes
and he was like hell yeah so he's my guy
we hang out I'll talk before we get to
that a little bit of news and stuff that
I just want to talk and I figure you
were here so let's do it let's do it the
Chargers are officially going with the
powder Blues as their home uniform next
season I have said that I believe that
this is in my mind the best Jersey in
the NFL I've put it on the IG and I will
say and and Twitter and a lot of people
are saying that the Raiders are the best
that the black and the silver and a lot
of people like traditional uniforms I
don't know I I do think the Raiders are
definitely up there I am very biased I
like the kelly green Eagles
I like the full eagle just like I think
Patriots fans like the full guy and not
just the flaming Elvis what else what
other ones am I missing which ones do
you really my favorite of all time is
the Houston Oilers which is kind of
where so a baby-blue the original full
oil rig and the red and the white with
the powder blue I think they were all
Thomas I think of Warren Moon 100% those
rows are so clean and the Chargers kind
of worked off of those that color
pattern thing so with the blue a little
a little bit the Raiders I do like the
Rangers uniforms but to go back to
class uniforms I don't really love the
Giants no I like the Giants more with
the full word and NY the old ones Farah
smooth onna on Twitter says what about
the all-black Atlanta Falcons that Vic
wore Vic but I also think it's the
Falcon where it's like the full wing
down you know if that if you can picture
that in your mind I think I had I when I
was with the red elders
I think the all-black Atlanta with the
red helmet like the Dion era was really
good another person here is Josh Richter
goes what about the Ravens all black I
just start thinking ahead read and rail
ooh yes no that's so good and then Alex
car he'll Slayer mm says here the 49ers
home and I think that might be like the
All Whites
yeah they have some classic uniforms the
Niners Ivan for as weird as the color
palette is I don't dislike Green Bay's
uniforms and then prodigy Merc goes the
new Jets uniforms should be number one
the white ones are great you do like the
white ones are amazing I don't like the
green or the black really the box okay
it's not great the shoulder thing is
horrible I just I don't think it's
possible to release a Jersey a New
Jersey and anyone's gonna like it I just
think everyone's gonna crap on it like I
don't well here's the dumbest thing the
jets release the jerseys and everyone's
like oh there are North Texas now and
I'm like there's only a certain amount
of colors somebody want here start was
saying is like there's primary colors
and that's all you can do but like it
always happens I don't remember the last
time a Jersey came out and everybody
liked it except maybe the Broncos in
97-98 maybe you know when the Eagles
went all black that was pretty awesome
when the Falcons released their
alternates but maybe it was cuz Vic cuz
a Vic people were like those are sick I
really think it might come down to the
players that wear it but no doubt from
all atoms made the Jets whites look
great yes that's why I think I like it
so much cuz what it came out and love if
you put like no offense like Bryan
winters or Kelvin Beecham in and I'm
like oh that's not good oh yeah so
excited about that guy yeah sorry Avery
Williams and I'm not excited speaking of
a former jet Ryan Fitzpatrick
has come out and said that he's gotten
really fat this offseason seen it
because he's eating too much birthday
cake from his seven kids birthdays so
we're gonna we'll think about it he's a
smart guy
and that he probably has his his babies
in the offseason so he's in peak
offseason form because he's eating too
much birthday cake who is Carlos
Williams from the bills member he said
he got fat because his wife was pregnant
and then he just ate a lot yeah but you
can't say that when 223 Fitz's yes yeah
it was just pretty big it's not a good
223 did you see the video of him jogging
no oh he's carrying a tire around his
stomach man well I'm not gonna make fun
of him because like I weigh more than
him and I'm six-two yeah but you're you
have a better frame oh well he's
carrying a tire left go there's in the
words of Sims I have well-placed fat but
he said he had three birthdays in March
March 1st 6 and 11th that's cake 6 out
of 10 or 11 days I
the thing about Fitzpatrick is this is a
trend this offseason Marcus Mariota
adding weight good way Jameis Winston
adding weight yeah Patrick mahomes
adding weight Ryan Fitzpatrick and just
say look just like these young bucks I'm
adding weight so what a new trend this
offseason this quarterbacks adding
weighting we a handle hits more but what
do you do when somebody has the reverse
whoa big offseason like Ryan Fitzpatrick
had the more big offseason like the not
the good one yeah like everyone's like
oh wow he got fat well no that's
typically when guys go vegan that's the
ultimate whoa big offs okay where they
just dropped 15 to 20 pounds because
they want to be like more indoor to
various Thomasson yeah and it's it's
undefeated in terms of not working oh
it's the worst like every single guy
that it's done it has portman more
injury prone the NFL season is a toll
what you weigh at the end is not what
you weigh at the beginning so coming in
streamlined is not a good idea but I
just love how these quarterbacks can go
I'm getting fat for the NFL's take the
hits it's unbelievable yeah but I would
say that my favorite thing I went on a
rant before he ended up getting his
contract which was Russell Wilson and he
gave the deadline and he said April 15th
midnight wheat West Coast time I need to
get a deal and I think I took I thought
two things one is the second time this
offseason a player has been able to push
a franchise around Antonio browned in it
and now Russell Wilson's doing it and
I'm getting a lot of comments and people
in my mention saying I don't like that
the NFL is going into the MBA mode where
the players can run everything they will
never be able to have that because the
playing careers are so much shorter in
the NFL than in the NBA LeBron is in
like year 15 or 16 we're never gonna see
anyone other than Tom Brady do that
stuff but I love it because they need to
have the power the other thing and
finocchio the founder of bleacher report
reached out to me and said what do you
think about these guys taking so much of
the salary cap and not letting enough
money to the rest of the players on the
team would a player wanna play for a guy
that is taking so much money and what's
funny is frank clarke tweeted out soon
after they lied to me no he didn't say
who they was yep but we have to assume
it was the seahawks and we have to
assume it was them going we can't a lot
that much money to any one player and
then they go out and give all this money
to Russell Wilson and then after couple
hours after he was like oh his family
related I'm with you right the hell I
doubt here uh here's the interesting
thing left go and I said this on sick to
football in the midweek show I've heard
that the Seahawks have already had
discussions about moving him and that
Clark yes and I know that he will not
show up the camp on the franchise deck
won't do it won't do it interesting so
that would be our splash next week my
argument for why I'm okay with Russell
Wilson if there's one quarterback that
really deserved this payday it's Russell
Wilson and you can say but Adam that's
taking away money from other people to
put around him hey guys this Seahawks
had the money during five years of him
being on a rookie deal and then three or
four years of taking a well below market
deal to put people around him and they
never did
I mean his best wide receiver over this
tenure has been has been Doug Baldwin
and they haven't really gone out and
gotten anybody like oh they tried to
trade for Jimmy Graham but they did it
at the expense of their offensive line
the offensive line for him has stunk the
running backs have been a turnstile the
coaching has been abysmal awful Darrin
bevel then they come out and get Tom
cable for the offensive waffle and then
here's Russell Wilson watching this
defense just get rid of players shed
Earl Thomas lose kam chancellor move on
from Russell affirm Richard Sherman if
any and all along this whole journey
he's averaged 11 wins in every year of
his career watching the Seattle Seahawks
over the last three four years has been
I don't know what happens on first down
didn't have a good plan for second down
hey Russ can you save us on third always
and so that's why if there's one guy
that has exceeded expectations and has
deserved to be paid for making up for
all the rest of the bull crap its
Russell Wilson and that's why I have no
qualms about it at all and that skill
set Eli Manning I got a problems is why
Kyla Marie's gonna go first overall
because they think he can do the same
thing but it's not your right left go
it's not an excuse you don't just ignore
other holes on the team or let Earl
Thomas go yes roll Thomas we're still
playing at an elite level and they just
did him dirty
let's call what it is so good for
Russell Wilson every quarterback that
has that leverage use it yeah use it I
will say though that I'd like to raise
this question to the homies what do you
guys think what do you think about
allocating all that money to a
quarterback does it set back a franchise
it really has to but I think it puts
more pressure on the front office to be
better at drafting and having a cycle
look at the Colts I also think that to
the people that say oh Tom Brady doesn't
take a lot I have heard from too many
people in the league that he's getting
paid under the table I just have and so
it's really hard to go oh that's the
model that everyone should be doing and
also his wife is a billionaire
it's a different type of situation and
he gets all the endorsement deals well
Tom Brady takes less listen individual
players looking for individual gain I
don't think it makes them selfish that's
what I'm saying I'm with you I think I
think really that the Seahawks have done
him dirty for a little bit but this is
the other aspect of it the video that
Russell Wilson put online to say that he
got paid needs to be discussed I put it
on the IG here's the audio that's the
word it's so weird
i'ma see y'all in the morning time for
y'all to go to bed the way he says bed
time for y'all to go to be a few things
I'm thinking here Oh God number one is
this Russell Wilson's voice all along
and he's been playing this
happy-go-lucky dude and he waited for
his big payday and now now listen
Russell Wilson's in the spot you gonna
run a go route you won't take us land
and don't worry fellas I'ma hit y'all
across the middle what if this is real
Russell Wilson and just like Antonio
Brown faked it with the golden moustache
and all that what if this has been a
long con also Wilson over the last
decade make him think that he's this I'm
gonna give it a hundred and ten percent
I'm a happy-go-lucky guy in dark garnet
I don't love him cause any problems
but what if new Russell Wilson comes in
the lock when we go loose in here Pete
is my team now bro like what if this is
the real Russell Wilson I think as soon
as that phone goes in front of him he
changes that he's just like dude there's
been so much [ __ ] with him the
miracle water loved it oh it's great
all the miracle water went into the lake
I'm just here for your eyes there I he
was let me say this what Russell Wilson
was when he first got into league into
now
he's cool now yes he knows what it's
like to be cool he dresses his hair is
different
he's got Sierra he's a girl super CL
evaded him if you're not with and this
goes to two men and women if you're not
with a partner that makes you better
that's not who you should be with I love
the man that Sierra has turned Russell
Wilson in he's really cool he's cool
he's got great hair he's got good style
and he's sitting here going he's Tom
Fiona go to bed the other thing that I
thought about and I played this for my
fiance and this might get cut but she
goes Adam you know when you talk like
that yeah I do know when I totally
you're well aware of it yeah when I'm
feeling real confident yeah and so my
thing is did Russell Wilson ink the deal
and then go mmm maybe a cocktail or two
yeah yeah like when you get to the house
not talking about that but yeah I'm
trying to you know trying to make sure
this doesn't get cut yeah yeah man I
thought the intro was weird though we
got a deal we good know we know like we
know yeah we all saw it
and then like his go Hawks was like hers
was like go Hawks and he's like go home
the other thing is too is like they're
acting like it's 6:00 in the morning
that news came out at like 12:30 West
Coast ice cozec on the East Coast it was
like 3:30 4 o'clock in the morning you
had every reason to go that's how they
acted it was like he's probably one of
those eight o'clock bedtime guys are you
kidding he's eight o'clock bedtime 7:50
glass of milk
7:45 like are you know what time it is
let's sing our goodnight song or the
will sins and we're going to sleep peace
but now I'm really hoping that Oh what
if all these years we were listening to
Russell Wilson but just like Steve Urkel
had Stephon this is Rochelle yes little
changes like he pulls up a car
yeah we're like a moat he's now a
motorcycle guy can do entourage yeah
yeah
yeah we're in leather Jack no haircut
like something he's already kind of
comes in with a sleeve tattoo and you're
like what fqo knows he's a leather
jacket guy I am I'm rocking a leather
jacket but I'm also thinking like he
walks in people like hey Russell is
Russell like ah I think this is the year
of Russell Wilson and I'm very excited
I'm with it but what I would really like
the homies to do is I saw a few of the
Seahawks Tyler Lockett and them do joke
videos I would like to see your guys
best in person nations of Russell Wilson
and I don't know if you want to do it
with your wife I would love to see some
of the women that love this show make
their husband be Ciara I just wanna I'm
gonna put together a compilation a
mash-up of all the best Russell Wilson's
and I want to put that out there all
right so we're closing in on the Josh
Allen interview yeah before we get into
the whole league what is the view of
Josh Allen I've seen him going as high
maybe as three to the Jets yeah I've
seen rumors of him going for the Raiders
what's your analysis of Josh yeah
realistically unless someone makes some
crazy trade for him I think it starts at
five with the Bucks I really do and I'd
be curious to see how they prioritize
their defensive line the interior
because Gerald McCoy is not gonna be
there for very long so I know that
everyone's connected them in the Jets
and Miller says it on sick the football
all the time
I don't think the Jets take him there I
think he's a great player over here say
this like knowing people I would be
surprised I don't even know if final
decisions have been made I just know
that Quinn and Williams across the board
in the league is viewed as such a more
highly graded player he's a lot and I've
been telling people what is Mike McKagan
done since he got to the Jeff Leonard
was Jamal took Leonard Williams when
they had Sheldon Richardson in Mohammad
Wilkerson he does not care that's
available and Quinton Williams is like
the sure thing of this class nobody
likes the sure thing more than Mike
McKagan all right so I would be
surprised at three Raiders at four is
interesting I keep hearing if Quintin
Williams doesn't make it to them they
really like Devon white hmm Joshua right
no and maybe they're playing every one
teams really like him he's raw as a pass
rusher he's an outside speed rush Josh
Allen yes
but he does so many things well whether
it's run and cover his speed he's spent
a lot of time with it it's a phase of
football guy he loves football
exactly you know scouts love this [ __ ]
yes and I get it I get the person
matters the other thing too is when you
have 17 sacks in the SEC that's a
statistic that resonates with everybody
it really does and you look at the you
know how his development has been I mean
he got to Kentucky he was 210 pounds and
we talked a lot about that like the
amount of work that he's done on his
frame I mean even just from his junior
to senior year he added like 20 pounds
yep but that's what the human body can
do and he puts in the time he's a dad
you're gonna hear a lot in the upcoming
interview about how he has one line
where he goes I genuinely think if I am
NOT in the gym I'm not putting food on
my son's plate and that's a level of
motivation that kids don't typically
have now and you can hear it with
everything he says there's intent and
it's motivation and it's not about am I
going to succeed it's how much can I
succeed for my son it's like his number
one driving focus and when you hear that
of course it resonates are you still in
the belief that it's Kyler Murray lock
at number I am I am you said it best
last time we did this show together this
is the month where the nonsense comes
out I have heard I don't listen to
anything I have heard some crazy things
that you know if they don't take him
it'll be Quinton Williams not Nick Bosa
that it's not a sure thing I think it's
Skyler Murray I think they've waited on
the Rosen trade to try to increase that
value I do think it's the Chargers that
have the most interest in Rosen
I know interesting everyone has said
Washington and I get the ties there I
know Washington really likes to Wayne
Haskins but they got to figure out a
plan really fast how to get him because
it's not happening at 15 I'd be shocked
I'd be really shocked so there's a lot
of dominoes that need to fall right now
laughs so let me let me pick your brains
do because we're about a week away from
the NFL Draft so I just kind of want to
get a setting of you talked to a lot of
people in the NFL but also you survey
the landscape of draft Twitter and draft
online thing you see Kyler going one
where
you see the range of Haskins oh that's
interesting I think it starts with a
trade up at three that's a little
unlikely if the Jets are looking to move
back and somebody whether it's a
dolphin's or a Bengals or a Washington
baby yep which teams do you think are
the most interested in asking Bengals in
Washington if somebody else comes out it
would be the lovely mystery team yeah
those are the only two that I got right
now for Haskins now here's the thing the
Giants do really like him I don't think
the Giants the Jets would ever do
business I don't think so which is why I
think it starts at 3 because those teams
know hey we might have to jump the
Giants when you like a quarterback you
don't risk it go see Sharon go well
maybe we'll make it but no like you
don't you make them mover you don't
Daniel Jeremiah put out a mock draft
recently and he does my tres what he's
been hearing yeah he's great at it I see
him put Daniel Jones to the Giants at
six am I supposed to go am I crazy or
the Giants crazy or as Dale Jeremiah
hearing things and maybe it's [ __ ] I
can't tell because I have had so many
people tell me the Giants love him at 17
right but sex bro I can't see it if the
Giants play Daniel Jones at 6 what grade
would you give it on giraffe night
I mean it's maybe a D if I'm feeling
nice by the way
giraffe show it's going to be live on
Twitter YouTube and the BR app if you've
seen our draft shows in the last five
six years it will be a very similar
thing the desk will be me Matt Miller
and Connor Rogers so in essence the left
go show plus stick to football we are
going live the entire time we will bust
draft picks before the television
broadcast does if they're talking about
it on Twitter we're coming in yeah we're
gonna do a quick video we changed it up
a little bit this year to where we don't
have to stop down as much and do the
videos but we're still gonna make that
content but we're breaking it down we're
not taking commercials when it's on the
seventh pick we're not going to be
talking about Kyler Murray so we're
focusing on every single pick I know a
lot of you guys love it so make sure to
check that out Thursday Friday and
Saturday for all the rounds Truluck what
are you hearing about drew luck because
in Daniel Jeremiah's Mach he had him
going like 30 don't think that's and I
haven't seen Sherlock go past the
Broncos or the Dolphins in any mark it
would be a surprise if he made it by
Denver
I think Denver knows that that's his
sweet spot he could fall them they don't
feel pressured to move up and get him
right what I'm conflicted is if this
Dwayne Haskins apparent slide that
everyone's been talking about which I'm
not buying starts to happen does Denver
have them great it differently whether I
thought we never thought Swain Haskins
might be here so drew Locke is such an
Elway quarterback that I am buying it
there's just a minefield of teams that
need quarterback yeah between 6 and 15
yeah and it's it's either teams that are
moving on and teams like Eli the Giants
or a team may be trading up like a
Chargers that have been really looking
for Phillip Rivers next for a few years
but then it's the Bengals
it's the Dolphins and it's Washington
and I think Washington and Miami the
interesting thing about Miami is do you
think Miami wants a guy in this draft or
do you think they're gonna wait for next
year I still think next year I know they
they love to Justin Herbert and we're a
little surprised when that's what I've
heard the Giants too same the Giants did
a lot of work on him teams really like
to uh they think to is in that you know
Brees mold where it's all touch throwing
accuracy from the pocket so if I
understand the Bengals because they just
brought in Zach Taylor at yoke and you
want to pair your young coach with a new
young guy yeah get that - yep that's
Washington Alex Smith who knows evolve
or play again yeah I don't think they're
counting on it right now I really don't
I think here's what I'm fascinated by
they're all sitting there staring each
other in the eyes like the good the bad
and the ugly just looking at each other
who is anyone gonna break first because
there's rumors Miller said Miller said
that the Dolphins like Daniel Jones at
13 and they would think about it at
gross
the Bengals like quarterbacks at 11
Washington wants one at 15 who's gonna
sit there and go well we can't risk it
here's my thing let's jump up but it's a
cost of 3 or 5 this year is not the cost
of last year this isn't the Baker
Mayfield Sam's Arnold's class I think
the Jets are the bucks or even the Lions
at 8:00 like you said huh they'll move
back for a reduced cost because they
they want to get the extra picks that
bass so if you're one of those teams and
you think Haskins is the guy
I wouldn't you just flip your second
round her but maybe sweeten the pot with
a 20/20 pic that's not a high cost no
for a future Kai that you think is so
who's gonna break first you can't just
sit there but they're all sitting there
right now thinking that everyone's lying
and someone's gonna fall I just I don't
think the Giants could take Daniel
Jones's six if I don't if the Jets don't
trade out at three is there a guy that
maybe not a lot of people are talking
about that you're here that you think
they like I love you know how much I
love that Oliver and when you see that
name come up in DJ's market it makes you
bat an eye a little bit where you're
like okay like at Auvers great football
player he's my second overall ranked
player then you've read it and you go
Greg Williams would use him on the edge
and you go oh we've only seen Alvar play
schanoes for most of his career but it
is Friday he was to 81 maybe you get him
down to 275 to 70
Minard Williams and Henry Anderson and
Steve London and then now you're talking
so if the Jen and Oliver is the perfect
guy on third downs if in the next year
or two or if they were able to get
Anthony Barr you put bharat and and you
can move oliver next to Leonard Williams
and go and what a perfect shade nose
like combo that shooter Oh phenomenal so
I'm I'm not fully buying that yet you're
not I'm not to the point where I'm like
that's happening yes I think it has legs
what is the position group how many wide
receivers do you think go in the first
round one to two so not a lot yeah I
think those wanted to being who they
would around in TK and what's the
highest they could even go Green Bay at
12
I keep seeing Baltimore taking DK
Metcalfe I think they go Center oh the
kid from Bradbury I do yeah I think
that's where that converse there are
there are certain guys when I look at
mock drafts that it always feet like I
always go to Sheldon Rankin's to the
Saints a few years ago where every mock
had that I feel like every mock wants to
put that guy that Center to the Vikings
because they've been looking for a
center for so long yeah I keep seeing
Noah Fant going to the Packers who do
you think goes higher just from let Noah
fan or Hawkinson will go higher Wow yeah
the stance the more Hawkinson 's range
starts at set
in Jacksonville and then you go into ate
with the Lions like that's Hawkinson
it's like okay you didn't go 70 could go
eight especially while Hopkinson sona's
a baby Gronk and then you got Patricia
there and Detroit looking like Patricia
will look at Hawkinson and love the
blocking great receiver how can you not
but he's an elite blocker for Titan who
is a player that gets drafted high from
what you're hearing right now that
common NFL fans go why did he go so high
oh I think people have concerns over
rashon Gary going top ten just because
all the hype and you know Michigan fans
are like okay who's all right where do
you stand on Rachelle Gary yeah I have
him I think 38th overall so Wow yeah and
he could go as high as he no top tenth
oh yeah yeah I could see me well the
Giants it's set easily Rashad Gary is
one I'm trying to think of some other
ones where people are Andre Dillard is
another interesting Washington State
Unemployment
how many tackles do you think as of
right now are looking like first-round
it just pens hat where you place them
but Jonah and Williams can play tackle
first rounder want Taylor is a tackle
for Cody Ford could be a right tackle
first rounder Andre Dillard first
rounder okay then you have the last
couple picks in the first round guys
that could sneak in titus howard from
alabama state
dalton Reisner from kansas state Alabama
state wild what play quarterback in high
school that's like Lane Johnson
that's what lady Johnson did I don't
want to calm Lane Johnson but like you
you get it he's got the athleticism is
could we see a draft with no corners in
the first round
yes but it would surprise me okay I
think Byron Murphy wide receivers and
corners it doesn't feel like there's the
upper elite guys and I feel like a lot
of teams are looking at second and third
round at those positions here's where
there's gonna be a run on corners I
think at the end I've heard the Chargers
and the Patriots both like corners in
this class and I've heard the Steelers
would consider the temple corner raucous
in in with their first-round pick which
is a huge asone type of corner get long
he's got arms down to the ground three d
williams byron murphy gosh so well there
should be a couple in the first round
but it's not like a class where you go
that's a first round you see just two
linebackers in the first round Evans
yeah the Devens and then how many D
lineman do you think we see on night
ooh counting edge and what are you over
under you think yes edge at interior has
to be around at least like nine run
through the let's do it so Nick Bosa
Quinn and Williams Edie Oliver rashon
Gary Montez sweat Brian burns Jeffrey
Simmons Christian Wilkins Josh Allen yep
that's already nine and then are we also
talking like all the Clemson guys like
Farrow Cleon Farrell and Christian
Wilkins I said Christian walk and so
pharoah would be what about Dexter
Lawrence I think he goes in the first
round I saw in DJ's mock and them having
him have going to the Patriots and I was
like that would be the worst [ __ ]
[ __ ] for the NFL ever 340 pound dancing
bear in that system it's like here's
Vince Wilfork yeah next decade I've even
heard some ties with him to the Giants
at 17
the Giants do like him which is a little
weird but I tell you right now I'd love
him in the [ __ ] Eagles of course like
you I know that you were looking at the
Eagles yesterday and it's definitely D
lineman yeah but I have a feeling you
were what was I think they would take
Jeffrey Simmons if he falls in them and
after my man Johnny Abram came in here
and talked about Jeffrey Simmons I was
like Helen he's a top five talent like
unquestionably a toddy tore his ACL yeah
but how are you gonna feel in the
postseason when you're getting one of
the best players in the draft on the
field that was the only the only reason
that Eagles fans wouldn't be too excited
is that was the thinking behind Sydney
Jones and Sydney Jones has not looked as
good after that yeah now it's a
completely different position yes and
but I think right now Eagles fans are
going man Sydney Jones better turn it
around right now I know are we gonna get
a running back in the first round Josh
Jacobs definitely I think so
who are the team's the Raiders are a big
one a 24 or 27 yeah if the egos in trade
for Jordan Howard they would have
thought about it yeah now they won't I
don't think so I just don't understand I
found the Raiders I'm not touching
running back no but you know I could see
groom just loving him at the same point
like man build your keep building your D
line keep building your score every yeah
like there's good ones in this class
every say but this one odd this one I'm
watching guys and I'm like damn like
this is gonna be a starter he's gonna be
around four or five pick when we're
going
to a pod here's the schedule that I'm
thinking for next week guys it's a
little bit up in the air I'm going to
Atlanta from Thursday to Tuesday so the
podcast that normally comes out on
Tuesday I'm a little bit unsure what's
gonna happen I'm doing a bunch of
interviews in Atlanta and I'm hoping
maybe something with Deebo Samuel might
come out Tuesday wide receiver from
South Carolina if not I will put it out
on social media that I apologetically
will not have a podcast coming out
Tuesday morning what I will do is I'm
doing a stick to football roundtable
with Connor and Matt Miller on Tuesday
afternoon I will try and get it out
Tuesday evening so that you have it
Tuesday evening Wednesday and Thursday
morning before the draft it's gonna be a
longer pod I'm gonna try and be a GM and
we're gonna go through the draft but I'm
also gonna go who were the sleepers at
every position I'll ask you that next
week that you can come up with who are
the running backs in round three or four
that could be the Cooper Cup for those
guys or the Tevin Coleman so we'll go
through every position look at sleepers
also kind of update everybody on the
rumors and all that and then again
Thursday Friday Saturday we will be
doing the BR live draft show right here
in New York City me Miller Conner Rogers
grading every pick going live taking
zero commercials and do what we always
do I appreciate you now enjoy all the UK
logos behind us because we were in
Lexington my conversation with possible
top five pick Josh Allen that amazing
Counting homey Josh as you can tell
we're in Kentucky right now we just
spent the day shooting some cool stuff
man it was nice getting to know you I
want to relax right now I want to I want
to relax the mood and your cool little
adidas jacket you know you like it
I do I do it's got three stripes like
you're supposed to be a top three
projected pick will see me April 25th 29
days Wow
first and foremost where are you right
now in your process like like what stage
is this how do you feel as nervous as
excitement you feeling I mean I'm at the
point now
like it is what it is I can't prove any
anything else now it's like so by
everything I'm just waiting so I'm just
like you know do my little my little
trips and like hits me guess so you know
all my nervous that I've been past my
nervous stage what was the most nervous
part probably you know dawn like right
after this season like some of the bogan
was over right like my life just changed
you know like drastically yeah so like
you know I had I had to talk different
to move different you know I mean I
always do so you know that was probably
the most nerve-wracking and she's
knowing that this is even for your whole
life yeah man so I noticed something on
all your social media posts like a good
amount two stars
mm-hmm this is like I could test so you
were a two star coming out of high
school
yeah and I feel like you've used that
for so long
yeah like but you lean into it like you
like I feel like you enjoy putting them
up do you enjoy it yeah I do
cuz that's always been you know my
biggest motivation before my son came
you know being just a two-star kid
overlooked be a first-team all-state in
my junior and senior in Alabama and in
Jersey the state of sacks in my senior
in like you know still getting
overlooked you know no teams off of me I
was coming in to Monmouth out of time no
so that was my biggest often in Kentucky
can your biggest offer was Monmouth well
now I'm not gonna lie like I looked at
pictures of you you did not look like
the way you look now yeah so like that's
one good thing you know I always thought
Tech me always thought cosmos for
development know somebody they're going
there and be the same person you know
you go to cause to develop you should
cause to be different you know I mean so
I was like that's what team looked at
didn't they're not didn't I'm you know
doing their job right we see you led the
state gets X and it was my first time
playing
Wow so and I was reading that there were
some D commitments and then and that
kind of opened up the opportunity yeah
so when I was told was I played against
actually played against one of my
coaches brother in high school and he
coached out a team you know killed them
and then and then like he told he
reached out to them I was like hey we
have a kid here just play you know he's
a dog
yeah and then somebody just decommitted
from here in to go to NC State and you
know we had a coach in the area and they
were just like I go see see you see yeah
you know so and then they came into
school then just gave me a scholarship
in and then back you got here what was
your weight I was like 205 205 and now
we're at 260 yeah geez Louise what kind
of diet were you like I gained weight in
college but not for a purpose just
because like Taco Bell and Burger King
we're right next to my door I mean I ate
but you know it's not great when you can
because you're trying to gain weight
especially now you know you can burn the
energy right on me so you can you I
can't you I took a whatever I wanted and
then like the next day burn it all off
so I was like you know but now it's like
I literally have to like you know I eat
what I want but like now I have to make
sure it's not like weighing me down
right thinking about other experts and
you're now a fine-tuned machine whereas
before you were like I just need to put
on weight and it was necessary
yeah but I didn't gain weight to my
senior so like I like I like gang wait
but like 10 pounds here they're like so
my first mirror my soft me my sophomore
year I was like I got to like 225 Wow
you know and in my junior year ago I
played like to 30 to 35
you were like linebacker weight yeah
like friggin yeah and then and then you
just pumped out like 25 how the heck did
that happen man is a good baby weight
yeah that's what it must have yeah damn
so my fiance was cooking every everyday
so that's awesome
you mentioned before that like your
motivation was two stars and now it's
your baby and I see you all the time I
saw this quote if I let you block me I
might as well let you take food out of
Wesley's mouth yeah it's an amazing
Instagram comment do you legitimate Lee
think that when you're on the field I
mean you know like you know I don't
think that what I'm going to feel but
like before I before I go before I do
anything like to come by that's what I
was thinking really like you're lining
up for the 40 and you're thinking you
know that's just my mentality but when I
play you know I don't think about
anything I just think about being the
best player on the field the short
winning every when you're in the weight
room
oh yeah like like that whole summer oh
I'm here to work right and I'm taking it
taking people with me you know along you
know cuz you always got to bring people
with you sure I brought people with me
and is just I'm focused like and if I
something I can't do like I'm gonna do
it you know I mean there's that if I
can't do I'm taking out whisky tomorrow
well we're all capable of so much more
than we actually do but it like fear
holds us back or like limitations in our
own head but like when you're living not
just for you but for your fiance and for
Wesley now you're like three people
strong yeah I know so now that's why I
had to play so hard because now I got
I'm not just worried about myself I'm
worried about two other mouths right you
know that's pretty expensive so I only
got a fiance and it's expensive let
alone a Wesley on my side I know and
he's at the point now well you gotta
order him food you know I mean he has to
order his own for stead of just eat
enough yeah yeah no we ordered him so
now it's like you know you got to work
hard to get you know they're comfortable
we're feeding through mouths you know
especially in college and you know so I
had to work hard and I just come off the
name Wesley Devon I always liked Devon
you know I mean see this man won't tell
his middle name it's not on Wikipedia
it's on the Kentucky Athletic guide he
will not tell me your middle name
you're not gonna tell me right now on
camera definitely not but if you did it
would be amazing I mean yeah their arms
was something but his middle name is bum
thing but but I guess Wesley well I'll
let you skate this one I'm not gonna ask
for your bill so I always like Devon you
know I'm like I always loved that name
so I was like are we're putting Devon
and somewhere and then Wesley you know
we were going back and forth with names
I don't like that I like that but I like
it yeah you know and then like it was
like one day I was like watching like
Dragon Ball Z or some and like and I'm
like Wesley it just came in - you know I
cut my cousins names Wesley okay
he's seven foot so I was like maybe you
know maybe I started a fight because I
literally thought that I was like oh
he's seven foot maybe he can you know
you know I mean I swear that's loosely
what I thought about and like in a puss
I like the name yeah you know so I was
like so I was presented to your fiance
exactly that but she but she didn't look
at the way I told her she's just like Oh
Wesley right oh she likes it now I put
Wesley devar now and then it's just a
flu and then I was like we can because
we wanted to ask something had a
nickname to it yeah so tocar what's to
become of Wes yeah so West wing's just
called West so you have a seven-foot
cousin and a sister in the WNBA in six
foot six eight uncle six six uncle a 6 5
grandfather Wow and sisters that are six
over five two-month
wait a second so when I saw your sisters
in the WNBA she plays for the Washington
Mystics yeah I feel like that has to be
such an advantage to see your sister go
and play pro and see what that takes and
the demand and all that like has that
been like a great learning lesson
for you I mean it definitely has been I
wanted to go see her play you know in
Atlanta and the song it was in our
summer so I see bright flashing media
days I want to go see you and like and
it was so crazy because like I
appreciate it and I appreciate the game
and I appreciated women's basketball and
what it took for her to get there
because like on TV is like then you
think about it's like yeah it's not
really as intent but then once you're at
a game sure it's like fast tempo it's
like they're competitive yeah they're
like really good you know man and that
made me appreciate it and then you know
it's just like the NBA women you know I
mean they're like the top players in the
country in the world you know I mean and
my sisters that compete against them and
it's like were you battling with her
like in the driveway growing up I mean
no could we were like never like oh we
could we have Florida sisters Wow you
know are you the youngest yeah I have a
twin brother
so really the youngest and you a four
older sisters raising you yeah
were they beaten you up were they making
you pretty like what what kind of
experiment was that I went through it
with them you know we had a good days
but we had a lot of bad days I'll tell
you that yeah you know just fighting and
you know a lot of fighting major tough
oh yeah for sure I rather live before it
sisters you know if you want to beat all
right a little four systems and follow
the brothers really yes you're gonna
have to prove what makes you give me the
girls are like voltage' weakest like
they don't care like you know what my
brother you know say they can beat you
up you know I mean but my sisters would
beat you up and plus it would be bad cuz
they're girls you know I mean and then
you know tell me everything like it's
tough you don't mean cuz I cannot listen
to my brothers you know I mean right
alright then you can you guys let's see
your sisters yeah
you know make it then plus they got to
move you know they can switch they're
moving up to par 5 I'd hate it
so what what advice has she given you
now that she's Pro she's the old sis you
better like we really don't be like into
like you know cuz she know you know she
bid she's busy she's a Russia oh yeah I
know his sister went to Louisville he's
at Kentucky they're rivals
yeah but you know what the crazy part
about that is we never were like I want
you to lose you know they because like I
was a Louisville girls fan when she was
a she was the Kentucky football fan when
she was there that's awesome you know me
so I want to her gain support of her she
went to my again supported me so it was
like but like with the other sports like
we never yeah yeah so it was more like
that but like you know we that was my
sister I was her brother you know we
always cheered each other on yeah you
know which and then it was always like
how do you feel at your service and you
know they try to get it a competitive
you know we're competitive but you know
support I'm always gonna support yeah as
soon as he left I've cut all time you
cut all ties I'm like men about Lube I
saw you doing the L down and stuff when
the pictures not to I also see in your
past that you were a wide receiver yeah
I'm seeing you in the jugs machine right
up on it catching the balls is this I
was a dog if you were a wide receiver
would you still be go to the NFL yeah
I'd be like yeah who would your pro play
Calvin Johnson Haley I'd be like yeah
baby magnet I don't know he was pretty
huge I I was Allstate receiving it on
you know made me bring up my days no I
want to hear about the days is this New
Jersey or is this Alabama news that I
was Allstate receiver in Alabama first
team all alright so time out so you
spent what years in New Jersey my
freshman junior my freshman sophomore
junior in Alabama oh and then I moved
back home to
for my senior Wow so you were Allstate
Alabama wide receiver yeah in like all
states yeah like Alabama I'm crazy
football like 3 3 a 3 a Wow 3 a like so
I was you know that was one of the guys
and then I moved back I move about the
Jersey and I became a you know Allstate
defensive player how come like how did
how does one go from wide receiver and
defensive that's the athletic gene and
did the team just need that position or
yeah it's like you know actually so my
first day going back home I want to go
meet with all the coaches and the head
coach literally told me who's like you
know you look like a defensive end
and you look like one of the could they
they're known for some difference in
Wednesday college and going d1 high
specialty so yeah so it was like you
look like a defensive man you like to
build all that I was like okay I don't
care you know I mean I'll do what it
takes you know so by the way here's my
resume I'm sorry yeah I play receiver
there as well so you know in Jersey but
uh yeah defense is just click so we need
to get you on an NFL team that will
throw you in on goal line oh yeah they
do I take I don't want to take nobody
spot now I got to put also saying
defense and don't be real tired
the Bears did it last year now tomorrow
I'm gonna be playing receiver like I'm
gonna be like you want to be out of like
second down yes
so they're gonna be like call me and you
know you're worried that you're so good
at receiver that they're gonna go listen
starting NFL receiver we're gonna have
to bench you yeah you know I shall in
the kid now so you know I don't want
don't want to take anybody you don't
upset anybody
yes I'm mistaken baby Megatron that's
amazing
alright let's get to the name when did
you realize that you were in competition
to be the most famous Josh Allen in
professional football so what age were
you like from googling or I've you know
so crazy because like at a young age I
got googled my name and it was like at
first it was like a dancer mmm he was
like a dancer I don't know if I don't
think I have it
service but I do feel like I should just
google it was like he was like a dancer
from like he was like going like Mary's
got I know he was like I'm one of those
popular dance shows so like I'm like so
in this dance or something yeah I think
it was puppy was I don't remember I know
he was like he was the first one you
know I mean so then I had to always type
whatever after my name you know and then
Josh Allen New Jersey yeah or like
Montclair right and then in the night
today there was another Josh Ellen from
like he went there like Arkansas or
something like that you know I mean so
it was always somebody and then when I
got better when I got good in college it
was like Josh Allen Wyoming you know I
mean it was him that always populated in
short it was him that his face that
would you start like researching them to
see like who this yeah I like message
him and we like messes back so this is
before he even got like big you know I
mean we love like talking to him and
like you know like you know good luck
you don't say it wasn't right yeah of
course I mean but then like it's like
it's kind of cool you're sharing this
experience with the same another Josh
yeah I mean and then like now freaking I
got now I'm like good but i typing Josh
Allen he still pops up you know me
because he's you know he did good so
it's like top-10 pick so it's like I
can't catch a break
so now it's a now I gotta get in the
league and so my second a couple times
and maybe I become the poster child of
Josh now you'll take your reclaim the
Josh you know name there should be a way
that if you start doing something well
like overtakes it and then I'd go back
and forth
yeah like it should be like a Google
poll to see who's the current top Joshua
no that'd be crazy at least you're more
well-known than the So You Think You Can
Dance guy I know it still cook about
don't see of no more he's not there
anymore there's all these other Josh
Allen's and now there's another one he
hit me up on Twitter another Josh Alan
there's actually like it's like there's
so many cuz like another one from Miami
Ohio he's coming out this year message
me and I'm like oh and I was like what
my fiance another saying man look at
this dude I even message me I'm like bro
so now I got I start talking to him
like a week later he made some music
yeah you know there's another one I said
yeah I don't break him up know whose
dude is but he told me about I was like
Madonna all right left go tiara there's
a few ways we could play this one you
could go by Joshua Allen mm-hmm
what do you think not into it - you
could go by Josh K Allen for your middle
initial yeah three we could just battle
this out with Josh Allen from the
Buffalo Bills and retake it yeah that
would actually be hilarious bad one if
you guys faced them and you guys had an
arrangement before the game and you each
came out and said whoever has the better
performance can own the Josh Allen name
that would be don't here's the thing
though what happens if you somehow end
up on the bills what if both Josh
Allen's are on the same team is this a
good thing
Oh suck why would it suck I thought it
would be a good like you know we can we
can work with that we can get that out
and you know the other brand that I sort
of say but like you know I don't want
people to get us mixed up yeah all the
time now since I'm like ice this can be
me like me him right it's like jaws here
I'll be I'll be just let you be Josh you
know that Gabe say say Josh Josh yeah
you don't want you know I may say see
now we got a look at the person you're
sticking your feet in the ground you're
not at all deserve that have very new
draft at ahead of him where he went
right hopefully that's the plan
he got you out to 1/7 I think yeah I
feel it all the bus right now is three
to the Jets for the Raiders what's it
like because we'll never experience this
what's it like to see yourself in a mock
draft do you start thinking about
yourself in the city I try not to look
at those as much project yeah you know I
mean like it's so it can be so different
from you know what
James and what all them guys say and
it's law like you know it's cool yeah
it's cool to see him finally see my name
up there but then you know I think I
should be higher you know me I hate
three or four but I think I should be
number one you know me
that's just type person I am you know
would you say that up to the Citrus Bowl
you said if I don't go number one I
don't know who with yeah and like you
know I still believe that you know
that's a that's a real belief that's not
you're just talking I've really believed
and I was like if you believe somebody
better than me you need to explain to me
why that person is better if you can
explain it yes and I've been alright you
know I mean the night so I don't worry
Tyler Marie could be a generational
quarterback why are you better than
calimary do you really believe that are
you guys I think that he has the
potential to be special not say that you
don't have the potential to go number
one you know I mean like you know
yeah he's I think you're more of a lot
than him okay so let's move on in the
next one yeah why are you better than
Nick posta I mean you know if you not
just better than him but like you know
everybody's this is a great defensive
class it isn't it everybody and like
this is like I said everybody is great
you know I mean like you're right like
all the top guys Cleveland in Oakland
say man that's all the long tears all
those guys and a lot of our players but
if you talk about now a week now we get
all past that now you talk about stats
you know I mean and like seven sacks
you know Defensive Player of the Year
you won every award and if you want to
talk to gursky if an Eric you know so
that's what that's how I bring it up you
know I mean like yeah those players are
good but if they were if you consider
them the best even Claire why are they
up for the war why didn't we know you
know I mean so that's just something I
feel about you know I'm not knocking
nobody like I thought all those guys I
can't ask my dog
yes you know I mean he's a dog he's
gonna get that's too hot I think both of
the dog he's gonna get you out too high
sweats hot sweats the dog Devon white
Devon Bush yeah you know a dog all them
dudes are dogs yes you know I mean but
if you want to talk about like if you
can explain to me why any of those guys
are
better than me just sort of say yeah did
not then I won't say it no more
but if you just keep saying just dudes
Bettany you and not bringing up any
proof then like I love that that's just
now you're just saying something you're
not giving out information you're not
giving out sign you know you're not
giving out proof you're just you're just
saying something I'm gonna talk to a few
of the defensive guys in the draft and I
feel like there's this weird bond
between all of you guys like am i right
with this I feel like it's like quarter
backs and wide receivers and stuff but I
feel like one a lot of you guys are in
the sec yeah - like I feel like a lot of
you guys were on the award circuit
together but it's not this like
competitive like I'm better than you I
feel like you guys are all like I love
your game do you know how I'm excited to
see I mean we all know that this is the
defensive drive we all know all the
title guys are defense you know players
and you know I have respect for every
guy you know I never I never crap on
nobody you know I mean that's just not a
person I am
apparently this isn't type of players
you know I'm going against you know I
sat down and talked to these people you
know like all the top player and I every
one of them are cool people no no no my
kago when we play football we're you
know we're not like this I'm gonna talk
crap to you you know they don't talk
crap to me that's just how we are but in
a formal setting and like if I'm talking
about another player I never told the
shade on somebody else
that's not just me and apparently that's
not and that's what raised is the
respect bar on these players drive yeah
I think it's kind of cool it's a
defensive draft yeah I like it I believe
this is probably this can be one of the
best you know one of the best defensive
drafts in a very long time
look I look back at Odell's drafts you
know that was a loaded read that was
that was the wide receiver draft you
know that was so much that was
incredible Taylor LaJuan was Ted Aaron
Donald was right there but like from a
wide receiver perspective it was Odell
Sammy Watkins Brandon cooks Alan
Robinson Mike Evans like it was so many
and like I'm missing like six guys brain
I think I said Brandon cooks like Jordan
Matthews are those like and and it's
those guys follow each other the rest of
their careers and that's how you're
gonna
with these guys on defense yeah it's
kind of cool I know do you have an
official sack dance you know every every
week I try to I did you know switches
don't do the thrusts good enough hey you
ain't got the hips for the whole thing I
could tell you doing all right good I
did speaking of dancing I saw you wrote
Von Miller I'm coming for your crown
what is the crown I mean at the time I'm
over is the best you know there's the
best defensive player in the league yeah
I use the best you know soccer Emily and
like you know if you want to be the best
you got to compete against the best and
you got it who do you think is the best
right now I mean I mean at my position
yes I'm opposition like Aaron no no
right now is the best you know I mean
but I can't compete with that man
because you know we're not the same
position by the defensive player yes I
want to be on that what about your same
position like coulomb a chimera are the
top guys are you someone that likes to
like put them on and study that homework
yeah for sure
that's where I got majority of my moves
from really yeah I learn from both of
those guys so tell me like tell me this
setup this is a YouTube thing is this in
your living room this is what you do
that this is like you know it started
off YouTube and then I stalk with my
coaches and we actually have a film you
know like NFL tapes and so I'll go back
and look at all those and see you know I
can you know go back rewind it pause it
yeah look at what they do so always
being real keen to those and getting a
good you know just you know just looking
at those yeah like learning different
things and seeing seeing if I could do
it and doing in the game it's like
really fun so you've actually had an
exposure ever a week we're like you
watched a booth and then went to the
game use the move and it worked you know
which wasn't was that it wasn't a move
this was like a stance like haven't I
saw always watching von Miller and he
did his outside foot up you know when he
passed to us so like I never did I never
tried to do it and I like saw it only
why he did it better get off really so I
didn't practice it in practice you know
I didn't go through it in practice or I
did it in the game you know I mean so I
did in the game
against Eastern Michigan had to sex so
they're out there now I'm like and then
I'm just every week I was doing doing it
and now that Coach white was here he
taught me how to really use it in like
you know how to kind of perfect it and
ever since then that's my favorite it's
exciting because do you have any more
new moves you're gonna learn the NFL no
like when it's your job like yeah like
what is it like to know like this is
about to be your career yeah I mean is
this is just like during school type of
thing anymore
I know another focus on your face bro
holy crap
and then I could focus on football now
you know I'm got to go to class
another's anything wrong but like this
is what you love oh yeah like I can
finally play football you know I can get
paid for play football yeah this is what
I love to do this is what supports my
family and like I get to do it all day
you know I mean but it still have a
still have time to spend with my family
right you know I mean so so when I
worked here in Kentucky there was one
shriek that never ended and Kentucky
fans needed it to end and it was the
losing streak to Florida I didn't
realize that this season it was up to 31
years
Kentucky hadn't beaten Florida in 31
years and I went back and I rewatched
the game and what didn't you frickin
know it at the end of the game you get
the strip sack to pretty much end the
game over Florida and then I'm reading
articles and you were actually in the
locker room with an IV that game and
then came back out so because this is
like man every I would go out to bars I
go out to restaurants and they'd say man
this is the year we bleep beat Florida
like all the time yeah tell me the story
about the IV like what happened in that
game I mean ya know Florida you know I'm
assuming a lot of people's been to
Florida but a lot of people this is in
the swirl this is in a swamp so this is
a night game so it's nice and muggy
so I cause catch a cramps all game and
you know is you came to town where I was
that all right I gotta hurry up and get
it so like we just got to fill I ran in
the back
you know me like come on yeah hurry up
give me Harvey and like I'm lying I'm
like totally people I say yeah I got a
hurry up like I gotta get back out there
like and I'm like talk to the one the
doctors I was doing it he was like I bet
you when I get out there I'm gonna give
me a sec you know me like I told him I
and the wall and they're like sticking
the I hear like I'm having an IV you
know in my arm and I'm just like ready
to go like and I'm here like and all the
noises hitting the crowd I'm like man I
gotta go yeah and then I was like I said
I said I might go back in this game I
want to get a say and we don't want to
get my sweater guy I told him that and
like you know I came back but you know
you could see in the game in the second
half like I got like the tape on me I
like went out there and lay so crazy
the crowd went crazy summarize like they
didn't score like what's happening and
their neighbor like run back in there's
like a limbo and just go to test down
we're girl oh yeah I got to go out
somewhere all right so I like run back
out there on the next series like okay
so they like wanna play on defense and
like I'm like all right there's like
just going woman I said no like the next
play I ran in there got to do down and
it was just like all right let's go so
now I'm in a series going and then this
is like the third quarter dog now I'll
get like a nice PB you you know make
couple plays here they're right and then
like the last series like right before I
got the side I'm like I like right
before you went out there I get my mind
right going through my ritual or
whatever and like just go out there
you've got games in like I'm a big
player this is a big time game yeah big
time play so you know I was going to my
mind
know when I you know got the sack you
know I'm like they didn't call it dead
so you know I thought it was like a
incomplete pass or cuz the ball went
flying off so I'm like so I just stopped
you can see I just you know got it and I
just like stopped looking in my I'm so I
figure out what's going on and like they
do you know our player picked it up and
was just he didn't know what to do he
just starts running for the ends no and
then he like stopped he stopped like to
he start like the one in one yard line
didn't go in a zone just
walk back by the throw the ball to ref
and the rest was just like and then like
he just like you know having to run
there yeah tackle him he caught the ball
in the end zone and then when they did
it
I'm not talking to referee yeah I got it
yeah I got to be a fun it's got to be a
fun book right by two things are you
know Rose field stands at the test town
I just go crazy I I'm white because it's
over like this second realization like
one you got a sec you force the fumble
you scored a touchdown and you finally
beat Florida on the water in Florida so
so yeah that was that was that was huge
and then plus and then white owed and
then heard the doctor I told it to us
like I told you what he was like he
Darren so dead like it was just like and
he was just like he did everything he
told me in and ever since then I've been
calling a lot of stuff I like I wasn't
know last time I wasn't they get IV so
they're not every time I'm in I said
watch this you know I mean and I've done
it you know I mean so I have you
predicted like made available go I got
the side yeah in this game I told my
trainer his game and like and so now
you're at a point where like if you
predict something people's like it's
about to happen and I try not to like
make a goal you know that's how to tell
everybody black this more of like a
myself yeah I know I like one person
Miss Cleo but it is crazy how that
happens but like you know it's just
adrenaline of course you know I know
that you faced drew lock in Mizzou and I
think I saw that the last eight drives
the game you guys had eight three and
outs and this is like one heck of a
quarterback yeah and then you guys end
up winning that you had two sacks on him
to keep swim oh I apologize that show
said two forced fumbles
two sacks to force phones he's a kind of
guy that I think people people are very
willing to say Kyler and Haskins or top
ten where do you think Giroux lock is I
mean drew lock he's a absolute beast he
played in the best conference gets the
best talent with nominally Kenyan yeah
so like he he slings it he's so
confident when he plays
yeah he's real he's a real cool guy at
that but he's real competitive as well
and like he just wants to win and I you
can see it when he plays uh you know I
believe he's one of the best
quarterbacks in his job not the best you
know I you know top three top two you
think there's a chance he might be the
best yeah really
I'm telling I've never seen anybody I've
never played against he licks it and
like it flies and they like and they in
it and this looks nice when he throws
the ball he's not throwing any ducks
would you say there's a lot of defenders
in the SEC that feels like maybe Drew
locks the best court officials draft for
sure Wow I will hope so you know I mean
and you know and I stand true today so
you don't seem like someone that would
lie at least I mean I think I not so
much that cats are not the line I mean
like yeah I guess the only thing I had
left for you is like you were 41 in
college 1y and - what are we doing at
the next level what are we thinking ah
so good story about the 41 yeah so first
day you know on campus I go to my locker
and like I see 41 Allen so I'm like all
right this is my locker number so hard
for the hole like this before we got our
joists online what's my number was my
number you just thought that was none I
didn't pick the number you know I
thought it was like but I thought it was
my locker number yeah you know I mean
I'm like alright this is you know my
Lockington was my own get a good number
yeah so we get our pressure at 41 I'm
like you're like oh wait for real right
and I'm like what number 41 like it was
just like so you didn't pick it I don't
know I had no but you just decided to
stick with it I mean I had no choice
yeah you could change after your first
year and you had to be good has it grown
on you yeah it definitely I'm saying
it's in like the so I was gonna change
it I'll go change in my senior or are
you gonna go to everything get to
but Dupree I was good I was gonna change
it but then I called my mom hmm
my mom I don't think my changing my
number number - she's like no see I just
bought all this stuff before anyone
you're not changing your number I can't
change it I bought all this 41 I was
like she's like no way like she said she
doesn't like it I was like you can't I
can't
so what are you thinking now I was like
now what something you can wear 40 want
the next level I mean maybe I mean maybe
it's like an outside linebacker if I
could so it's growing on you just
because you know I mean yeah it has yeah
it's gone me but like you don't see
anybody else working for you and here's
something wild my 8th grade year you
know my locker number was 41 it's my
first Locker I knew that was you but
that's interesting so it started off you
being like damn and now it's like if I
can get that the NFL sure well I I'm
ready to get a number how excited how
ready are you to be drafted right now
man I'm ready to see what's in the
living it's like what team I'm gonna
make great again so you know I'm just
excited
it sounds like you're ready to be an
Arizona Cardinal hey they gave me they
better be for some league why don't you
know what would you say to Arizona that
you should be the first pick in the
draft
you know forget all the other teams
you're trying to go one I mean if they
want you know if the okay did I cause
then if they looking for a team fit and
they don't need my position okay you
know I won't be mad but if you want the
best player and I in a drive you know
then the suffix 1 is self-explanatory I
really but I got to the point I was like
I really can't fight for myself because
like my game speaks for itself
you know I mean everybody knows what
type of person I am you know on and off
the field so it's like you know they
know what they're getting any team knows
they get it they're getting me you know
I mean and I want to make a team great
you know I want to bring every ounce of
me
and not help the team you'd be great
again and that's what I'm here to do and
we'll see I appreciate you breaking
greatness to this my man pleasure
getting to know you like wow seriously
good luck with everything
appreciate it yeah we'll be doing
something again I look forward to it